-Our next guest is performing
in Central Park this weekend
as part of the Wild Hearts tour.
Performing "All the Good Times"
from her new album "Big Time,"
please welcome Angel Olsen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I can't say that I'm sorry ♪
♪ When I don't feel so wrong
anymore ♪
♪ I can't tell you I'm trying ♪
♪ When there's nothing left here
to try for ♪
♪ And I don't know
how it happened ♪
♪ We've both abandoned
the reason we used to believe ♪
♪ Was it love that we shared
when we easily cared? ♪
♪ Now it's impossible
to conceive ♪
♪ I don't know who can see ♪
♪ If you've ever learned
how to let someone in ♪
♪ Well, I've tried to come find
you ♪
♪ But I just don't know
where to begin ♪
♪ If you've ever been open,
there's no way of knowing ♪
♪ With the way that knowing you
has been ♪
♪ Was it always so broken if
these thoughts were spoken? ♪
♪ Would it bring us together
again? ♪
♪ Probably not ♪
♪♪
♪ I can't say that I'm sorry ♪
♪ When I don't feel so wrong
anymore ♪
♪ And I can't tell you
I'm trying ♪
♪ When there's nothing left here
to try for ♪
♪ Well, I won't be the one
to keep holding you back ♪
♪ If there's something you're
missing, then go right ahead ♪
♪ I'll be long gone ♪
♪ Thanks for the songs ♪
♪ Guess it's time to wake up
from this trip we've been on ♪
♪ So long, farewell ♪
♪ This is the end ♪
♪ And I'll always remember you
just like a friend ♪
♪ And the way that you said
as heavy as lead ♪
♪ You've always known how
to get straight to my head ♪
♪ Thanks for the free ride
and all of the good times ♪
♪♪
♪ Thanks for the free ride ♪
♪ And all of the good times ♪
♪♪
And I just want to say thank
you, Demi, and thank you, Jimmy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I also want to say
yes, Chef.
And I want to say happy birthday
to you, Demi. Happy birthday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thanks for having us
on the show.
We got some more shows to do,
one in Central Park,
and we're gonna keep on rollin',
so God bless.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪